you ever heard of the healing power of
laughter
get out of here Batman or so Batman came
out in 1989 it was directed by Tim
Burton and it was a very different kind
of Batman that we had there were some
dark graphic novels I came out before
then but this was the first one that
mainstream audiences got to be like wha
so that's Batman no pound no swap no
swap and they get hit all really dark
gothic all right that's cool I mean
you had Michael Keaton his Batman some
people were like what but a little known
fact about comedic actors they have a
dark side inside them they can pull from
that it's why they're funny because they
deflect with humor he totally worked as
Batman he didn't talk a lot when he was
in the suit he was just like you know
walking around like I'm Batman that's
how he said it he didn't have a throat
infection like that although I preferred
the bail Batman that's just me that like
Christian Bale Batman was more stealth
than Michael Keaton's Batman I mean
Michael Keaton's Batman used stealth
tactics like he'd jump off a roof people
look down he's gone but in the end
Christian Bale's Batman was Ninja Batman
I like Ninja Batman the funny thing you
think about things like you know Vicki
Vale is his love interest in this movie
it's Kim Basinger she has her Padawan
obi-wan Kenobi braid on the side of her
head from the 80s and she's like oh
what's with that Ally and then they do a
lot of digging and find out ah Bruce
Wayne's parents were shot in that alley
you think that would be common knowledge
to be like Bill Gates parents being
killed I think everyone would know about
that but I guess this is a different
take on Bruce Wayne and Batman Begins
Bruce Wayne's a public figure in this
Batman he's just as rich guy who knows
rich people and I guess a lot of people
don't know about his past
yeah well that's fair enough one of the
downsides in his movies Commissioner
Gordon I like the Commissioner Gordon
that works with Batman they collaborate
you know they do cool things for trying
to take out crime did you see that the
mob is really prominent in this movie
crime is huge no one likes Gotham it's
just it's the pits but Commissioner
Gordon never works with Batman I mean he
gets the bat-signal at the end of the
movie but really there's no
collaboration I feel like if
Commissioner Gordon was never in this
movie at all the movie would be no
different - kind of sucks to make
Commissioner Gordon kind of a weak
character like that but one of the
strongest points in Batman is Jack
Nicholson's Joker in fact this movie
should have been called Joker that's
more or less the origin story of Joker
and Joker just killing everything so dey
call it Joker and Jack's Joker for what
they were
this movie was completely awesome I can
see where he fries the guy with the
electric ring he's just like he had that
crazy lack for people laugh so hard like
they're out of breath I would I like
about this is there's no definitive way
to be like oh that's the only Joker that
exists ever I say that about Heath
Ledger's Joker but in reality it's all
opinion I mean the movies are kind of
like comic books and graphic novels you
have different stories different takes
different writers different ways they
portray the characters and that's what I
like about this if you like Heath
Ledger's Joker awesome you have that if
you like Jack Nicholson's Joker awesome
you have that with all these different
takes on the Joker character in the
Batman stories you can kind of pick your
poison but I am gonna compare this to
the Christopher Nolan Batman's because
well it has the Joker and his Batman and
well he's done that too and for me I
loved this Batman so much because of the
Joker when I was younger and then the
Christopher Nolan Batman came out and I
found a Joker that I personally liked
more so then I looked back at this
Batman and I'm like hmm I like this
Joker less than the Heath Ledger Joker
personally so the movie loses a bit of
its gravity for me because the one that
carried the Batman movie in 1989 was
Jack Nicholson's Joker makes sense a
doesn't mean however Batman is a
kick-ass action movie it has a cool
villain played by a really good actor
who I will say was probably born to play
the Joker in 1989 I will say less acting
was applied from Jack Nicholson playing
The Joker because it was just natural to
him he's Jack Nicholson on screen in
fact I don't even know if he knew he was
being filmed that being said it worked
for the movie and this Batman was a leap
it was a really ballsy move to take
Batman it is such a dark tone since
before that we had pound man wampa never
like okay I'll have Joker fry people
with a ring the only person I've ever
met who didn't like this movie was this
real art freak back and looked the 80s
or early 90s my family knew her she
a chicken when the Joker and his crew
that one guy that looked like a Bobo
from Double Dragon was just going nuts
painting over all those paintings yeah
she didn't like the movie after that I
laughed just because she didn't like the
movie I wasn't a dick as a kid I swear I
will always have a spot in my heart for
this movie I bought it on blu-ray and so
I will give it the rating I would buy it
and did buy it on blu-ray however if you
live and die by the Nolan movies and
you've never seen this movie before you
might hate it because it just doesn't
have what you've grown to love just
being realistic I'm not saying it should
or shouldn't be like that that's just
this situation all right so your
favorite Batman villain of all time
we're talking favorite Batman villain
and where he or she was represented
graphic novel movie cartoon animation
doesn't matter comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more